uh good evening brit you know obviously
this hits
close to home and it takes the focus but
we've been talking about this issue for
weeks now in big cities across america
politically how does this fall
it's hard really brett to overstate how
dangerous an issue this is for biden and
the democrats
if they are unable or unwilling to do
something that will reverse this
trend around the country in major cities
and elsewhere
of rising violent crime and if you put
that together with the situation on the
border where you have lawlessness
just rampant even though not all new
media are really covering the story it's
pretty visible
uh in a number of places and people i
think are clearly aware of it and what
it looks like
is that this the lawlessness
is not being seriously taken and
seriously combated
and if the pres and if the view takes
hold
that that is also true in the cities as
well uh and there's a lot of history
here
i think uh this is a very dangerous
issue for
for the president and his party in the
upcoming midterms and maybe even sooner
brett i'm going to read something from
politico which as you know is not
considered a right-wing
organization it's it's covered in
washington for a long time but it says
this the biden white house
has a sophisticated antenna when it
comes to emerging political threats
see crime and immigration so the fact
that the president is addressing
inflation head-on means his team is
concerned
i i guess that's you know we've seen
these crime events
from the white house we saw an
immigration event
and now the president is talking about
inflation those things start to add up
and they try to get ahead of them
before they become political problems
well i think that's right and that's
and it's smarter than to do that the
problem is of course that holding
meetings and making statements
uh may set a proper tone
but if the results on the ground on the
border and in the city
streets don't change
the perception will take hold that all
they're doing is talking about it and
not really trying to do anything about
it at least not do anything that's
effective
and you know when you've got the police
union in dc saying that politicians
won't let them do their job that is
unmistakably a democratic government in
a very democratic city
washington d.c and that pattern is
repeated to some extent all across the
country where
the police are bailing out taking other
jobs retiring and so on they're having
trouble recruiting police officers
this is not going to be laid at the
doorstep of the republican party this is
much more likely to be laid to the
doorstep
of the party that governs nearly all of
those cities and that of course is the
democratic party
so it's it's you know politically
dangerous and hard to shake
last thing as we head towards 2022 the
importance of
of the crime issue and how deep it hits
i mean
most times elections we point to the
economy and how people feel at the
kitchen table
but the crime issue really does hit a
different place
oh yeah that it is one of a handful of
issues that people can feel and sense
and if people feel endangered in the
city streets where they in the streets
of the cities
where they live and and even beyond
they're not going to people are not
going to vote to
to keep that going they're going to
register a protest about it at the polls
and that is typically what they do in
midterms anyway even against you know
presidents who are not that unpopular
uh presidents tend to lose seats in in
their first midterms
anyway so the political calculus of this
you would think would be
becoming increasingly urgent in the
biden white house although i'm not so
sure that it has i mean holding events
as i say
is is fine but doesn't go very far it
doesn't help much
all right brit as always thank you hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now